in india millions of people are mourning
the death of one of the country's most
iconic singers lata mangeshkar has died
at the age of 92 after being
hospitalized due to a covert 19
infection last month
[Music]
known as the nightingale of india
mangeshkar's lilting voice dominated the
airwaves for decades the bollywood
superstar received dozens of movie
awards and sang more than 15
000 songs in her career
india's home ministry has declared two
days of national mourning flags around
the country are flying at half-mast
our delhi bureau chief amrita chima is
covering this for us amrita what are the
reactions in india to the news
then the reaction to lata mangeshkar's
death are huge the president said he was
heartbroken when he heard the news of
her demise the prime minister came out
and said she was a blessing to humanity
television stations and radio stations
have wall-to-wall coverage about laga
mangeshkar's death they're replaying her
old interviews they're playing her music
people are paying tributes social media
is full of that some of the most moving
tributes ben are coming from the
bollywood fraternity especially
musicians who she's so inspired and she
was very fond of cricket so the cricket
team here is also mourning her loss and
they're all wearing members of the
cricket team black bands in memory to
lata mangeshkar so there's a huge
reaction people it's fair to say the
whole nation is mourning the loss of
what india describes as the nightingale
of the country and abroad as well uh
that voice is just absolutely amazing
tell us more about the significance of
lata mangeshka for indian music and
cinema
you know she started singing when she
was uh five years old and she was
trained in classical music but lucka
mangeshkar looked down on bollywood
music till she had her first kitten that
was in 1949 she was just 20 years old
and after that there was no looking back
she sang for over half a century some 30
000 songs in almost 40 languages and she
lent her voice to some of bollywood's
most glamorous film stars which she
herself remained very austere in her
lifestyle now the thing is that the
playback singers remained quite faceless
before lata mangeshkar came on the scene
and she worked very hard to get
recognition for the playback industry in
which she was the most dominant voice
now she had a whole range of music that
she sang apart from bollywood sad songs
happy songs religious songs and one of
her most iconic songs was about patricia
artisan she sang and paid tribute to the
soldiers of india who died in the 1962
war and when she sang that song the
prime minister of india at that time
nehru was in tears she won practically
every award in the country the high
civilian award so people really she's
leaving behind such a huge void because
she was such a dominant voice in the
indian music industry that
this void will not be filled easily just
briefly how do you feel amrita you grew
up with this music and and hearing that
voice
actually not just me ben i think
practically there's no one in india who
doesn't know laka mangeshkar and her
music and as i was mentioning this song
that i told you about paying tribute to
indian soldiers it brought not just the
prime minister to tears when i was
listening to the uh to this song this
morning i was in tears as well i'm ready
to cheer for us in delhi thank you very
much for bringing us the latest on that
story
i'm joined now by dw correspondent
namisha jaiswal namisha what have
reactions in india been to the news of
her death
one writer coincidentally wrote that
provided the soundtrack for our lives
her music covered eight decades and this
is definitely a good reason why across
india now many indians are remembering
her fondly
yeah such an icon in india but for
people around the world who may not have
heard of her tell us about the
significance of lata mangeshkar for
indian music and cinema
when rupakashi is mainly recognized as a
playback singer so she's sang for the
music tracks that we often see in
bollywood movies where the pictures are
of the actors and actresses but the
voices are of singers like
but many those
many of those remembering her today find
even that title reductive because she is
remembered as the nightingale of india
she had she sang from the young age of
13 to provide support to her family and
sang in over 40 languages she won many
national awards and as well as film
awards and she was actually one of the
people who fought for the institution of
those film awards because playback
singers were not given that amount of
respect when she first came into the
industry she also broke into a male
dominated industry and is now one of the
most well recognized voices in indian
cinema and indian indian singing i would
like to close out by talking about how
one famed poet remembered her he said if
you take all the fragrance all the
moonlight all the honey in the universe
and put them together you would still
not create a voice like hers and this is
how india remembers that
that is beautiful such a sad day for
india dw namisha jaiswal in delhi thanks
very much
you